welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in as we look back on the whole
infinity saga the heroes who first come
to mind as the ones responsible for
defeating Thanos and Avengers endgame
are the big names Ironman capped off
like Widow Hulk spider-man
Hawkeye Black Panther Doctor Strange
Captain Marvel that it's like let's
doing a lot of names for sure step two
show and for some reason the students at
Peter Parker's school include a vision
in that grateful tribute so sure him too
but what do you think about it this team
effort was even more of a team effort
then we've been acknowledging I would
argue that the victory in endgame was
even more factor of the unsung heroes
who are simply not given enough credit
I'm going to shine a light on the real
heroes of engage in this special update
to of inside Marvel's
we should begin by acknowledging that
more than anyone else
the MVP most responsible for the in-game
victory was without a doubt Scott Lang
now don't get me wrong everyone played
critical roles and many others
sacrificed far more than Scott Lang did
but until Scott returned from the
quantum realm and showed up on Kappa
Nets doorstep babbling about time-travel
their situation was hopeless
it was also without that hope so you
know hopeless in many ways and if you
watched endgame closely a ton of
background details reinforce ways that
Scott continues to be a crucial team
player when Thanos his ship levels
Avengers HQ buried in the rubble Rody's
war machine armor gets crushed God
checks in with him and behind him in the
background is the new replacement war
machine armor that Rhodian zap hermit
crabbing into we don't see it happen but
when Brody surfaces from that rubble in
his new armor it must have been Scott
who told him where to find it during the
opening charge giant Scott also provides
Peter Parker a giant hand to swing from
so that Peter doesn't have to use clouds
or ps2 game helicopters solid assist
spider-man Returns favor later on by
setting them up to stop collab Citian
Solid dunk you might have also noticed a
shot in which giant Scott can be seen
shoving a Leviathan through a portal
presumably one that opens into someplace
terrible like the Florida Panhandle
now since this was edited to take place
while Scott was technically normal-sized
jump-starting the van some have said
this could actually be Hank Pym but if
Michael Douglas was in this battle they
probably would have showed his face so I
am ruling continuity error that gives us
another reason I love Scott Lang now
related to Scott's contribution is our
next unsung hero police I am of the
belief that Lewis belongs in every MCU
film in a post-credits scene that recaps
the events of the movie in his amazing
storytelling style the car line we
you'll see he's pleased to be fine right
the bartender's are like yeah crazy
stupid fine Lewis does not get a cameo
in endgame but he does make one critical
contribution his ex-con security van
sure it's a Hank Pym tech within that
van that they used to engineer quantum
tunnel but it is Louise's addition that
saves them in the midst of the battle
we need to get it back where they came
from no way to get him back Thanos
destroyed the quantum tunnel hold on
that wasn't our only time is she
[Music]
now sure they know smashes that ban so
they can't use it but it is in this
place that they corner Thanos in the
final dog pile
so that star can wrestle those stones
off its knuckles essentially the end
game of endgame it's triggered by Lewis
blowing a battle horn this final battle
is packed with interesting details and
background assists that really just make
it fun to re-watch but there are two
small highlights that I want to point
out here because these fighters are not
given enough credit and in game first
team Groot if you look closely in the
background behind Scott and Hope at one
point you can see one of the aniseh
soldiers
sneaking up behind rocket ready to kill
him but at the last second Groot
branches up grabs them and pulls him
down never even saw it
a similar save happens for mantis
barreling up behind thorne cap is this
Chitauri gorilla that's the actual
technical term for them but if you watch
closely
mantis rides it presses her hands on its
head and then knocks it out cold
she also hops off and gives it a little
kick who knows how many she did this -
how many leviathans we got acknowledge
that mantis Groot in any of the back up
here would not be in the battle without
the freaking miracles by the sorcerer
Network of Doctor Strange and Wong in
the arrival montage notice that one of
those portals opens up from contrack sia
the snow planet from guardians volume 2
and from that portal comes the Ravagers
including people like Raglan and Howard
the Duck of all of these portals only to
lead to offworld locations the sorcerers
are located all over earth which allows
them to create portals to places like
Wakanda and new Asgard in Norway now the
portal to Titan was of course opened up
by dr. strange who dusted on that planet
so who opened the portal to contract SIA
and how would the sorcerers know to go
there to bring in some fighters for that
answer we go to one of the post-credits
scenes and guardians of the galaxy vol 2
when yondu's funeral led to the reunion
of an eclectic group of Ravagers headed
up by sylvester stallone esta carro
Gordon I think he'd be proud knowing
that we're back as a team
don't I miss you guys so much yes
what say we still so [ __ ] this red dude
is Krueger
he is a limb sorcerer in the Marvel
Comics in the alternate dimension earth
six nine one crew is the disciple turned
successor of Stephen strange as the
sorcerer supreme so as one of these
sorcerers in strange and Wong's Network
Kruger must have served as ambassador
and recruitment officer for all the
Ravagers on contracts eeeh he is a major
unsung hero who doesn't even get a cameo
in endgame but the most unsung of all
in-game heroes does get a cameo
not even one faked with VFX the rat the
hero that made all a Scott Lang's hero
it's possible the end may be behind the
MVP VFX artists Jen underdahl explained
not too long ago that the rat that
crawls across the pin tech controls to
release Scott Lang from the quantum
realm was so important to production
that they insisted on commissioning a
train to perform a rat instead of
generating it with CGI for those of you
who are curious that is not a digital
rat as actually be practical acting rat
I don't have his name but he's really
there the Russo brothers have stated in
the film commentary that this rat is the
true hero of the Infinity Saga and there
might have been even more significance
to this little hero than we realized he
and Scott actually might have a history
in the first ant-man when Scott
accidentally shrinks down and hank pym
stolen suit he stumbles into a crawl
space in a random San Francisco
apartment and runs into this rodent
could this be the same San Francisco rat
well probably not Scott met this guy in
2015 and the rat that freed Scott from
the quantum realm did so in the post
blip year of 2023 so this thing would
have to be at least eight years old and
rats tend to only live two to three
years also there's at least a 50% chance
that the first rat was dusted and
there's a 100% chance that the end game
rat is actually Loki who do you think
was a real hero of the nfinity saga
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on twitter and instagram at a
boss and follow new rockstars and social
setting rockstars and subscribe to us on
youtube to join us as we go deeper and
deeper inside marvel a land where the
most important figure is a
[Music]